[Music]
sony has detailed the PlayStation 4 is
next firmware update and a bunch of
people will be happy to hear that it
adds external hard drive supports I'm
Matt and you don't need any extra space
to enjoy this gamespot news update
according to the playstation blog update
4.5 Oh allows users to connect external
hard drives that support USB 3.0 and
contain up to 8 terabytes of storage
once you've got yours connected you'll
be able to download and install games
directly to the hard drive other
editions that come with the update
include custom wallpapers a more
accessible quick menu and a new boost
mode for ps4 pro owners which gives the
option to improve performance in games
that haven't been patched to support the
pro those phone is available in the 4.5
0 beta update and players have already
found that it's made some noticeable
improvements to specific games frame
rates however Sony didn't detail boost
mode in its announcement post so it may
not actually end up in the final four
point 50 release the invites to the beta
update were sent out to some of the
users who signed up today there's
currently no scheduled date for the
ps4's upcoming update but will report
back when more information becomes
available and for all your news on
playstation and the world of video games
stay tuned to gamespot